hello rejects I call them rejects pardon
they love it
they kind of like it reject fans Greg
here Jason Horton back on the channel
since our la-la-land movie review yeah
really want to say this again but we're
in America where America this time I
want to say the best movie of the year
watch I'm gonna keep promoting that film
until it comes out
youtuber just an average Jess request
that we do xoxo and you Netflix original
and he says it he thinks it looks
horrible he wants us to watch it and I
say like you know what cost of getting
[ __ ] where people want me to love it
let's see if this is actually as bad as
he makes it out to be right
you tinge to book you a slop I'm sorry
give it back Sarge so I can make it up
for some pledge in the past life
tell yourself on the king of this
kingdom is amazing your whole life is
gonna change
I tell these people to like I've seen
more DJ's that you can count coming up
easy business
whoa the easier it's gonna be for you
this music means everything to me I'm in
this because I love it
this is real music you just happen to be
the soundtrack to getting wasted or the
background of a car commercial make that
connection
it gets you outside yourself yeah
huge party going on
where these together trust me
they were gonna play an amazing set and
I am gonna be there
this is your moment you gotta grab it
the house the real plot of that show or
movie white people miner can be where's
the drama going on exactly you know it
should be taken seriously when there's a
lot of disco still doing this which is
like I think completely updated at this
point why would I even know that yeah
it's on Netflix that gives me like I
automatically want to give it like at
least a three without even seeing it oh
yeah son Netflix okay well you know I'll
say some positives I'll say some
positives rave scene could be kind of
interesting to watch I've been to every
winter rave I hadn't know I've been to
one rave okay
the ecstasy did not work very
disappointed with the ecstasy I got not
gonna say his last name Brandon you
hooked up some horrible pills it's a
prank
what's up Brandon dude and I saw you on
he you look a you're having a great time
yeah I feel [ __ ] I'd take ritalin so
check feeling the music though I kind of
felt the music I really don't understand
raves so much unless you are like
drugged up cuz you're just dancing with
a crowd facing a DJ yeah it's a guy
playing music it's not like a live band
yeah I do play music with a bass part of
like it's people watching times a
thousand you know bigger colors and
rings and they're like eating candy or
wherever this going and I thought like I
thought a rave would be like a bunch of
like orgies and stuff it's not that at
all no it's not that at all it could be
very disappointed girls yeah I mean when
you go to raves everyone's like half
naked yes very revealing but no sex so
it's like uh this guys getting a chance
of a lifetime he's got one shot to be
the best DJ in the world and it's not
guaranteed so he's a little bit upset
just looks like it's like she's trying
way too hard to be something more than
what it is yeah
my caching unlike the edn thing a little
bit it just feels like that yeah I would
be more interested in seeing like a
documentary about it okay that a lot I
feel like everything I feel like I've
never see a documentary on this yeah I
don't really feel any real characters or
real
I'm going on here I'm not that into
watching or listening to that kind of
music only for a film like I like give
me some give me some actual characters
to be drawn to here yeah I mean you have
that one guy who you know you always
have that that dudes like oh this isn't
this here oh yeah that's the most
character it's not talking about how
rave music is so important and that's
the top of it like yeah important thing
I just don't get how you can argue that
it's like a very specific kind of crowd
when you go to rape people there to get
drunk or do drugs and just get lost in
music
yeah or the people that are just like I
I want to try something like this once
yeah yeah that was me a lot of first
time I mean he's always the first time
is I think it's a lot of first-timers
that never go back I went in a suit not
a good idea
yeah on purpose I know I thought it was
a formal event no but I was wrong yeah
it was very wrong did you end up with
those suit at the end of it there was
yeah yeah I haven't asked you by the end
okay yeah things people do to go erase
them yeah a lot of weed going around a
lot of a lot of pretty people a lot of
pretty colors yeah it's cool it's cool
like boyfriend and girlfriends go yeah
but the boyfriends can't steer all the
other hot chicks well I'd watch it you
would like garbage it just doesn't look
like entertaining garbage
I like entertaining garbage I don't even
like entertaining garbage I think it's
really garbage yeah cuz this looks kind
of dull and like it looks so see like
this is how long so and held like if
it's two hours that's a problem is that
a guy friend about DJ movie like the
subway or yes we are friends let's be
friends something like yeah but the
other had a character in it we are
friends we are your friends I just I'm
not sure what exactly the I mean it's
just a trailer so I can't judge the
movies sure sometimes you can know yes
when I see something like this I'm like
are you trying to explore the lifestyle
of this are you focused on care what's
the point of it was the message exactly
somebody living the dream in the road to
kind of getting there see what there's a
little road trip kind of aspect to it
I don't know I just doesn't generate any
kind of there's this thing like to be in
any real purpose or drive behind a
nothing here you maybe not yeah [ __ ]
like that one shot like I have what
maybe the addition is you just saying
you get one Trevor Trevor Michael Trevor
sin whatever yeah cuz they're having
dialogue like that where you're like you
get one shot you know you got you got it
right yeah but at the same time I'm like
why is this have such a dark vibe though
hmm like it doesn't look like this is
the glory time this this feels let
anyone die I hope so
these are odine people die raves all the
time either some Oh Dean oh dude any
time I watch a guy OD uh happiest moment
of my life yeah cuz then I'm just like
wow I didn't OD no they did though suruc
you did not OD I did not OD did not OD
and Zuri Camelot McDonald's I also do we
almost had heart disease fella yeah in a
matter of days voting that no OD'ing
something tells me this film kind of
wants to be like a film for the youth
you know I'm not like run without a
cause but what's out doing you know it's
a it's out this summer like that was the
kind of thing so I feeling it has that
summer they're trying to cash in on that
like it's summer be free but any wasn't
really timed right for the summer yeah
it's like the tail end of the summer oh
it's already out I think it's already
are people requesting that I watch this
I think it's already but if it's out
it's only out like recently I'd be more
interested if it look like he was trying
to have fun yeah cuz this is about going
to a rave and the raves are about having
fun but this seems like a drama or like
just like there's a girl that's going
there he's gotta meet the girl you know
that classic story yeah something about
something to me to latch on to a little
personal because I'm like if you're
gonna do a movie about a rave like the
EDM inspired like make it look fun don't
make it look like a dark drama then try
to infuse inspirational lines throughout
it I just don't quite get the marketing
behind this this if I have more time
going always like sure you wear wait
like wings on this set this like this
girl should wear wings or not the people
that usually make these I feel like
there are people that are really don't
understand the culture and they just
kind of do their idea of what that is
yeah it look like an adult making a
judgment about the youth bracelets we
have girls making out sexual exploration
weird events in their hair people like
me doing alright guys well that's our
review for XOXO if you're new to the
channel
today become a reject Oh Jason Horton
Jason tell me why you're so famous why
was he with my looks my body my talent
tell me your track record instead ah my
track record is zero I'll try to promote
you in that you were writer and actor
for total he's been totally sketch yeah
yeah he was a writer and actor for
totally sketching bit parks and some
movies and TV shows logic yeah and he's
collab with a lot of people actually uh
my new movies coming out but he was just
at the premiere for late in America yeah
I mean that isn't that and a lot of
other youtubers are in that tubes so
yeah Jason Horton he's quite known and
he has some funny-ass sketches and he's
collaborated a lot with Lauren Francesca
has been on this channel so go check him
out there let's give a shout out to
Lauren Francesca yeah Lauren you're
doing a good job with the photos your
postings keep it up you're getting the
right amount of likes congratulations I
wish I had boobs